the good thing is that the clean energy
revolution will be mostly led by private
capital even in the meltdown that we're
seeing right now the one place it's
still strong where venture capitalists
at least are still looking to make big
plays the clean energy sector the
handwriting is on the wall for the
carbon-based oil-based coal based energy
outmoded 8-track tape kind of
technologies people now going to move to
the mp3 solar and wind clean energy grid
technology so that's still very strong
the private sector will lead but the
private sector can only do a good job
according to the rules the government
says I'm all for markets but markets
work according to rules and the rules
are set by the government right now the
rules are wacky if you are a polluter
you can dump all the carbon in the world
you want you for free in the air and you
pay zero for doing that it's going to
cost us the whole planet but it's free
to you that's the biggest market failure
in the history of capitalism that's got
to be corrected well you corrected by
either having a cap-and-trade system we
would say cap collect and invest system
so the money you get from people who buy
the right to put up carbon you reinvest
in the economy or you carbon taxes but
you've got to get the sick the price
signals going so that it's suddenly
cheaper to be clean and more expensive
to be dirty right now it's cheap to do
dirty energy and it's expensive to do
clean energy in part because of price
signals are wrong so the government the
most important thing the government can
do is get the price signals right to get
a carbon deal done that puts a price on
carbon that makes forces polluters to
pay so people will vary and I guarantee
you very quickly the energy sector in
our country the minute that that deal
goes through they're going to come out
with a whole hat magic hat full of
technologies that are ready to go the
minute they know they can't go on the
old way but we've got to get the price
signals right
well then there's there are objective
and subjective hurdles objectively the
polluters spend an awful lot of money
engaging with radically legalized
bribery of the entire political system
we have a military petroleum complex
that runs this country i call the texas
to pentagon axis runs right through the
Bible Belt where I grew up where my
family still lives that up until now has
run the country i would say into a ditch
and as a result we have this incredible
addiction to oil overseas as well as
well as homegrown one but we spend a
tremendous amount of our Pentagon
dollars defending and protecting and
policing oil supply lines why so you can
then spend billions more buying the
stuff well I would say you know a smart
thing to do would be to take ten percent
of the Pentagon budget and use it to
retrofit repower reboot America clean
and green so then we don't have to have
military bases all around the world and
guard sea lanes all around the world
that is the way forward for the US
economy the the faster we can transition
to a clean and green set of homegrown
solutions for energy the quicker we can
get energy prices down and start growing
the growing the economy
you